c'est devant la presse c'est en présence
de nombreuses personnalités que les
autorités sénégalaises ont lancé leur
campagne de vaccination contre le coc
vie 19 le ministre de la santé a ainsi
reçu une dose du vaccin produit par le
laboratoire chinois sinopharm le sénégal
avait déjà reçu la semaine dernière 200
milles 12 du sérum qui affiche une
efficacité de 79%
le vaccin est déjà utilisé par plusieurs
pays africains
mais le sénégal et le premier situé en
afrique de l'ouest a lancé sa campagne
une vaccination qui concernera dans un
premier temps 20 mille membres du
personnel de santé et des personnes
âgées
la sanaga aujourd'hui le sénégal attend
également de recevoir des doses à
travers l'initiative kovacs piloté par
l' oms les autorités négocier avec
d'autres pays notamment la russie qui va
lui fournir son accent spoutnik v depuis
fin novembre le pays est confronté à une
forte augmentation des cas de kovy de 19
pour les autorités sanitaires
sénégalaises le vaccin est l'unique
solution car l'heure actuelle la
vaccination constitue le que de la
préparation on ne peut pas s'en sortir
sans cette vaccination
j'appelle toute la population à se faire
vacciner
je les fais parce qu'il faut joindre
l'acte à la parole donc pas qu'on sait
les gens à signer cette campagne de
vaccination démarre sur fond de
polémique
les occidentaux ont accumulé les doses
de vaccin au détriment de nombreux pays
pauvres et notamment africains le
président sénégalais ainsi demandé à
emmanuel macron de veiller au partage
des vaccins reçus par les pays les plus
riches
le président français a proposé que
l'europe et des états unis livre le plus
vite possible et 13 millions de doses
aux pays africains